de l'autre côté du pacifique ce ne sont
pas les communistes que certains veulent
convertir mais les gays c'est gai qui
s'affiche sans complexe lors de leur
fameuse gay pride de san francisco le
plus grand rassemblement d'homosexuels
au monde
ils sont en effet la nouvelle cible des
conservateurs des ultras de la droite
religieuse pour les homosexuels sont des
malades et il faut les soigner
une théorie qui malheureusement gagne du
terrain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
seattle au nord de la côte ouest c'est
la troisième communauté homo des états
unis et c'est là aussi qu'est né l'un
des mouvements les plus homophobes du
pays
exodus financé par des chrétiens
radicaux exodus refuse que
l'homosexualité et pu être rayés
officiellement en 1973 des listes de
pathologie mentale
pour exodus négation des malades et on
peut les guérir pour faire de bon aux
hétérosexuels
un discours relayé dans l'édition la
presse voire même dans la médecine
puisqu'une centaine de cliniques
labellisé exodus ont été ouvertes à
l'attention des homos selon
l'organisation tout cent mille d'entre
eux on aurait même déjà franchi les
portes vous pouvez avoir des tendances
homosexuelles mais nous nous vous disons
que vous avez le choix de vous en sortir
de vous diriger vers l'hétérosexualité
plusieurs d'entre nous sont passés par
là et aujourd'hui nous nous en sommes
libérés nous avons des femmes et des
enfants et pour la plupart d'entre vous
c'est un formidable message d'espoir
rebecca et lesbiennes mais elle vivait
mal c'est elle qu'il dit son
homosexualité
une cliente idéale pour exodus tous les
vendredis soirs donc elle participe à
une psychothérapie de groupe qui
s'appuie sur des réflexions pour le
moins orientées comme vous le savez
quand on aperçoit un iceberg
on en aperçoit cadière les deux tiers
sont en fait en dessous de la surface
elle oui quand vous examinez quelqu'un
qui a des tendances homosexuelles ou qui
luttent contre son homosexualité c'est
la même chose
l'important c'est de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé dans l'enfance avec maman
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec tapas à
la famille le stress les amis enfin tout
ça c'est pareil
ce que je vous propose d'essayer de
comprendre c'est comment identifier ces
problèmes est l'une des solutions bien
sûr c'est de faire appel à l'aide de
jésus-christ pour qu'il vous aide à les
résoudre et
pour justifier le rejet de
l'homosexualité
exodus s'appuie évidemment sur la bible
dont il propose une lecture assez
simpliste et très premier degré ipad dur
avait planifié les choses autrement
quand il a créé et la fan ouamane a créé
la femme pour le la jeunesse de la bible
le dis clairement et ne bégaie sur les
conseils d'exodus rebecca donc tout
plaquer ses parents ses amis son
quartier pour ne pas rechuter et céder à
la tentation et c'est dans la plus
grande solitude qu'elle essaye donc de
réinventer sa vie et de comprendre son
histoire
[Musique]
j'ai été élevé dans une famille
chrétienne
j'ai rencontré mon mari quand j'avais 16
ans à 18 ans nous étions mariés à 23 ans
car nous avions deux ans qui mariage a
duré 13 en l'air jusqu'à ce que
j'abandonne ma famille pour devenir
lesbienne
au début j'ai trouvé que c'était
formidable
j'avais enfin ce que j'avais toujours
voulu d'un point de vue affectif et
physique
mais très vite je me suis rendu compte
qu'une partie de moi n'était pas en paix
parce que je mettais séparer de dieu
cette souffrance est devenue si forte
que j'ai même envisagé de mettre fin les
jours hier encore marginale les
associations comme exodus ont connu
récemment un rayonnement indéniable au
point d'avoir les moyens c'est à dire
des centaines de millions de dollars
pour financer ces spots télé cyrus veut
tout à la gloire des homos repenti
j'étais gay pendant 13 ans quatre ans
pour moi et tous les deux on s'en est
sorti nous étions perdus cherche sur
l'amour mais pas au bon endroit
ce n'est qu'à partir du jour nous avons
rencontré jésus que nous avons été
sauvés voir une femme des enfants je
croyais le rêve impossible mais il s'est
enfin réalisé
si vous vous sentez blessé seul ou pau
mais jésus peut vous libérer
[Musique]
face à ces thérapies pour le moins
douteuse l'association des
psychanalystes américain réagit pour
rappeler que l'homosexualité n'était pas
une pathologie
[Musique]
ce n'est pas nouveau
dans le passé il y a eu une multitude de
méthodes thérapeutiques qui ont été
expérimentées pour essayer de changer
l'orientation sexuelle certaines
personnes ont subi des traitements de
choc électrique
certaines ont reçu des drogues qui les
faisait vomir toutes sortes de méthodes
plus cruelles les unes que les autres
visualisation hypnose
vous aviez l'embarras du choix
rien n'a jamais prouvé qu'on pouvait
changer l'orientation sexuelle de
quelqu'un les gens qui subissent ce
genre de traitement fini stévia mans
déçu avaient quant à eux un sentiment
d'échec de honte parfois ils sont
incapables d'avoir de nouvelles
relations intimes
le patient peut avoir et crif d'amboise
faire une dépression
cela peut même le conduire au suicide
j'ai changé
il a changé j'ai changé il a vraiment
changé
et moi aussi j'ai changé à l'image de
ces deux mots qui disent avoir changé
avec le sourire anthony affirme lui
aussi avoir définitivement modifié son
orientation sexuelle
devenu militant d'exodus il revendique
haut et fort son statut d'ex au mot et
pour lui aucun doute le changement est
possible
[Musique]
il est
à l'époque où j'étais homosexuel j'avais
des centaines d'âmes ans je couchais
avec n'importe qui je sortais dans
toutes les boîtes de new york puis à 26
ans dieu m'a libéré de mon homosexualité
il m'a dit que si je continuais j'allais
mourir du sida et grâce à l'aide de dieu
et bien sûr en suivant la thérapie de
l'organisation exodus
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir ça a été aussi
difficile que de décrocher de l'héroïne
la plus grande épreuve de ma vie
[Musique]
homosexuels pendant dix ans anthony vite
aujourd'hui après deux ans de thérapie
exodus dans un pavillon de banlieue
entouré de sa femme et de ses enfants
anthony a rencontré son épouse diane à
une messe de minuit
elle a décidé de relever le défi épousé
un ancien nos maux susceptibles de
renouer avec ses vieux démons
[Musique]
ça a été dur au début
même si anthony avait décidé de quitter
sa vie de gay et continuer à être
sexuellement attirée par les hommes
aujourd'hui anthony prétend ne plus
regarder les hommes et selon diane il
serait même un mari tendre et
attentionné
diane de son côté était hétérosexuel et
un peu des pavés moi de mon côté j'étais
homosexuel mais dieu nous a sauvé tous
les deux de cette vie malsaines
c'est lui qui m'a orienté vers
l'hétérosexualité
aujourd'hui je suis heureux d'être un
mari un père et anthony est un militant
très actif
le jour où s'est tenu à washington le
congrès des psys américain il était le
premier à manifester pour exiger qu'ils
reviennent sur leur condamnation des
théories d'exodus
mon dieu vos fils et vos filles sont
aujourd'hui à vos pieds et au nom de
votre fiche jésus nous nous implorons de
changer l'esprit de ces psychiatres
comme à rouvrir les yeux pour qu'ils
nous voient de leur ouvrir les oreilles
pour qu'ils nous écoutent
nous sommes un gros textes au monde et
nous voulons vous faire savoir que nous
avons besoin du soutien des psychiatres
nous sommes là pour vous prouver qu'il
est possible de se débarrasser de son
homosexualité
grâce au pouvoir de jésus et grâce à une
bonne thérapie chrétienne mes pulsions
homosexuelles ont presque disparu
je suis ici parce que je suis un ex gay
j'ai changé mon fils de ville on peut
changer c'est possible
ne vous inquiétez pas moi je suis resté
dans un hôpital psychiatrique pendant
quatre ans regarde et je me suis coupé
les veines j'ai bu du poison j'ai même
tenté de l'immoler par le feu
j'ai tout fait pour me soigner de mon
homosexualité finalement c'est grâce à
jesus que j'ai réussi à me guérir moi je
n'étais même pas capable d'avoir une
érection de faire l'amour à une femme
maintenant avec la mienne tout va bien
moi je suis très sceptique je pense
qu'il est très peu probable que ce genre
de thérapie marche sur quelqu'un qui est
vraiment homosexuels
pour quelqu'un de vraiment motivés
c'étaient éventuellement concevable le
problème c'est qu'ils prétendent que
cela peut marcher pour tous les
homosexuels
moi je dis que si ça marche cela ne peut
être que pour des cas vraiment
exceptionnel charlie rose est ce qu'on
appelle un nex ex gay c'est à dire un
homosexuel devenu hétéro après une
thérapie exodus
mais ensuite revenu à la case départ je
continuais à regarder les hommes et
j'avais des fantasmes il y avait
toujours un gay qui se mélangent aux
alentours de 1993 j'ai craqué je n'en
pouvais plus et je me suis dit que quel
que soit le problème pour dieu il
saurait s'en débrouiller charlie devenu
théoriquement été retenu ainsi près de
10 ans son rôle d'homo contrarier dix
ans de faux semblants de questions et
surtout de mensonge non seulement aux
autres mais lui-même
[Musique]
j'ai même essayé de sortir avec des
pavés évidemment cela n'a pas marché
j'ai souffert de dépression tellement
j'étais frustré je n'en pouvais plus de
jouer la comédie et d'essayer de me
convaincre eu que j'étais quelqu'un
d'autre
finalement je me suis dit là c'est
terminé
je n'en peux plus si cela doit être
comme ça pour le reste de ma vie
faire semblant d'être quelqu'un d'autre
pour faire plaisir la société non ils
peuvent oublier
nous voici à dallas l'une des villes les
plus conservatrices du sud du pays
cette cathédrale gay est un pied-de-nez
aux conservateurs soixante quinze
mariages homos ils y ont déjà été
célébrés financée par des dons
individuels la gate schurch espère
développer un contre pouvoir capable de
concurrencer les discours radicaux
d'exodus son credo on peut avoir la foi
et est trop beau
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens qui utilisent la bible pour
exclure les homosexuels et les
lesbiennes de la famille de dieu on les
traitant de pêcheurs sont les mêmes que
ceux qui avaient utilisé la ville pour
exclure les femmes de l'ordination et
pour justifier l'esclavagé dans ce pays
il y a juste ici nous avons des milliers
d'ex au mot et qui ont soit disant
changé avec la thérapie exodus et puis
quand ils se sont vraiment regarder en
face il était toujours au beau fait je
ne connais personne qui ait réellement
changé d'orientation sexuelle je connais
des gens qui ont changé leur
comportement ça c'est leur choix ouais
cependant je ne vois pas de raison de
faire ça si vous comprenez bien que les
homosexuels sont autant les enfants de
dieu que les hétérosexuels
[Musique]
soutenir les minorités leur ouvrir les
portes des églises
c'est également le credo à new york de
tous ces croyants qui ont décidé d'aider
les toxicomanes à sortir du crack et
pour ce faire
eh bien ils chantent le gospel car dans
ces quartiers noirs
cette chorale et pour des centaines de
toxico new yorkais le seul espoir de
revivre un jour normalement toutes ces
années ça a été l'enfer
je peux vraiment dire que j'ai vécu
l'enfer que j'en suis sorti
[Musique]
mon seul but maintenant c'est de planer
enfin je veux dire uniquement sur le
plan du bonheur assez de ces fausses
illusions tentation et autre déception
le bonheur c'est tout ce que je veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le centre de réhabilitation de l'arca
situé en plein coeur de harlem l'ancien
ghetto noir de new york depuis 1958
plus de vingt mille personnes ont essayé
de décrocher d'abandonner la drogue à
l'aide du gospel entrepris hier et
musique
le remède semble dérisoire mais pourtant
monsieur allen comme on l'appelle ici
est le fondateur du centre accro à
l'héroïne pendant dix ans il a connu le
même destin les mêmes difficultés que
ses pensionnaires la rc la victime
habilitation center c'est un havre de
paix pour moi sans doute parce que sans
ce centre je n'aurais pas survécu
minimes 1 c'est tout ce que j'ai dans la
ville faire chanter a capella des
drogués en cures de désintoxication n'a
rien de la sinécure
absentéisme des motivations dépendance
autant de handicaps que monsieur allen
combat sans relâche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la chorale a commencé avec six ou sept
personnes
nous sommes allés dans une église pour
demander la permission de chanter et
parler de nos problèmes d'argent mais
ils ont refusé
[Musique]
alors je suis revenu avec les 150 types
qui vivait au centre à l'époque
et quand ils nous ont vus débarquer ils
nous ont laissés rentrer et chanter ça a
été le plus beau concert de toute ma vie
je crois que dieu était avec nous car
jamais aucun de nous n'avait si bien
chanté à la fin du service
nous avions récolté 400 dollars et là je
me suis dit qu'en continuant comme ça
nous pouvions trouver l'argent qu'il
nous fallait pour faire vivre le centre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je me suis dit aussi que dieu ne
nous avait pas aidé uniquement pour
l'argent mais aussi pour faire passer
son message d'espoir
[Musique]
reggie williams à l'arc et celui qu'on
appelle quand un membre de la chorale ne
donne plus signe de vie
inquiétude ce matin à propos de sony le
vétéran de la chorale absent depuis
trois jours sony chanter à l'arc depuis
20 ans fragilisé par des années
d'accoutumance à l'héroïne
il a quitté le centre il ya quelques
semaines pour vivre dans une maison de
retraite
malheureusement sans surveillance
médicale ready conscient des risques que
court l'ancien toxiques ou a fait venir
les secours mais il est trop tard sony
est mort cette nuit d'un arrêt cardiaque
le coeur fatigué par la drogue
les gens prennent de la drogue parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas affronter leurs
véritables intentions
alors il cherche à éviter tout ça grâce
à des substances chimiques
quand survient un événement aussi dur
que celui ci ceux qui avaient l'habitude
de fuir grâce à la drogue se retrouve
complètement désarticulée et encore une
fois cet ensemble en musique et en
prière que le coeur va apaiser sa
douleur dernier en âge à sony une
nouvelle profession de foi
et oui dit oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah oui quoi